[Music]
welcome to water's world i'm jesse
waters a december to remember that's the
subject of tonight's waters words
the annual white house christmas tree
lighting is always such a special event
except joe biden the president seemingly
forgot he was supposed to light it watch
president biden and first lady dr jill
biden
[Applause]
this went on forever
no joe
maybe he thought barack was going to let
it i don't know
these things just keep happening every
single week i kind of feel bad for ll
they needed to do a second
take sit down again one more time
all right now
president biden and first lady dr jill
biden
[Applause]
[Music]
so how are we supposed to feel confident
the president can crush the virus when
he can't even get it together for a
christmas tree lighting
this is a disaster
the new kovid 19 variant omicron now
spreading throughout the united states
i'm not worried about the new variant
i'm worried about how the government is
going to overreact to the new variant
biden's got a new plan more masks more
testing
but unvaxed illegals can just pour
across the southern border without
testing without quarantining and then
joe packs them onto planes and buses and
sends them to your neighborhood
does that make sense to anybody
dr fauci as you advise the president
about the possibility of new testing
requirements for people coming into this
country does that include
everybody everybody who's coming into
the country needs to get a test within
24 hours of getting on the plane to come
here what about people who don't take a
plane and just these border crossers
coming in in huge numbers that's a
different issue
if fauci was serious about stopping
kovid19 he'd tell joe biden to stop the
caravans
and joe biden might even listen to him
at this point fatchi may as well be
president
i've seen more
of dr fauci that i have my wife we kid
each other but
they look who's president fauci
we're in deep trouble this december
biden's so dismayed though that people
are politicizing covet i know cover 19
has been very divisive in this country
it's become a political issue which is a
sad sad commentary
it shouldn't be
biden literally got elected because he
politicized kovitt
220 000 americans dead
if you hear nothing else i say tonight
hear this
anyone is responsible for not taking
control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain as president of
the united states of america
now there's been more deaths in 2021
than in all of 2020. so by joe's own
logic he shouldn't remain president
joe biden got dealt a huge blow in court
all his vax mandates were blocked and
then he suspended his own federal vax
mandates until after the holidays
holidays where shoppers can just get the
gifts they want right
well
i went to go buy an ipad mini for my
daughter and the apple store says it
won't arrive by the 25th
wasn't joe biden supposed to have fixed
the supply chain crisis when he made the
port stay open 24 7.
i spoke with the ceos personally spoke
of the ceos of the major retailers
walmart target and the leading freight
movers fedex and ups
they assured me that the shelves will be
stocked in stores this holiday
but now he's singing a much different
tune
now i can't promise that every person
will get every gift they want on time
only santa claus can keep that promise
maybe i should just loot my gifts this
christmas that's what the rest of the
country is doing smash and grab thieves
targeting stores from california to new
york and everywhere in between
does the white house even know that
that's going on
so when a huge group of criminals
organizes themselves and they want to go
loot a store a cvs a nordstrom a home
depot until the shelves are clean you
think that's because of the pandemic yes
that's their answer every time something
goes wrong just blame the pandemic
i'm sure the gangs grabbing louis
vuitton handbags think they're filled
with monoclonal antibodies
no jen they're likely out on bail from
another crime spree
another major problem joe's not doing a
damn thing about bail reform
the waukesha christmas parade attack
left six people dead after daryl brooks
jr purposely plowed his car into a crowd
a black nationalist and convicted sex
offender with a felony rap sheet posted
low bail twice this year after punching
his girlfriend in the face and running
her over with his car
joe biden dead silent on the waukesha
massacre but wouldn't shut up about kyle
rittenhouse last year disgraceful
police officers that have been shot and
killed in 2021 are at an all-time high
in almost every major city murder rates
are the highest they've been in three
decades
now americans are loading up on guns at
historic rates since democrats aren't
doing anything to protect them they have
to protect themselves
not only is america violent
it's too expensive
family is getting rocked by inflation
and high gas prices a vicious cycle the
biden team can't get us out of
after taking two-month paternity leave
mayor pete now says if you're worried
about gas prices just buy an electric
car
there is more envisioned in the build
back better law i'll give you one
example it contains incentives to make
it more affordable to buy an electric
vehicle for families thinking about
getting an ev families that once they
own that electric vehicle will never
have to worry about gas prices again
hey pete uh if you're having trouble
paying three dollars and fifty cents a
gallon you probably are going to have a
lot more trouble paying fifty six
for an electric car
i don't think these people have any idea
what the cost of living in america is
today
just sit back and relax in this plush
hammock corey
seven
seven
thousand
seven thousand seven thousand actual
retail price eight hundred and eighty
dollars
mayor pete's now the odds-on favorite to
win the 2024 democrat nomination
the media has put joe out to pastor
already and they're maneuvering mayor
pete ahead of kamala harris how weak of
a bench do the democrats have if these
two are your best options
a white male intellectual who's openly
gay
versus a woman of color
neither of whom has shown any ability to
win the black vote or the white working
class vote
when they push joe out it's going to be
an identity politics bloodbath that'll
rip apart the democrat base get the
popcorn out
but for now those two
need to make it look like they love each
other at least
isn't that sweet
hard to tell if that's actually mayor
pete or just not one of those child
actors kamala likes to hire for pr
purposes
and if joe and his team ever need help
the time is now
this december they need their press
allies more than ever
let's check in with constitutional
scholar joy behar
when the founding fathers uh were busy
with the amendments the first and second
amendments did not have ar-15s in there
weapons of war and they didn't have
twitter so both amendments i need i
think need to be tweaked a little bit
you know we make our living on the first
amendment so we love it but there's a
lot of hate speech and misinformation
needs to be dealt with
she's a talk show host who spews hate
and misinformation who wants to tweak
the constitution so she can't spew hate
and misinformation
joy behar can't even be ironic without
sounding like an idiot
and joy is joe's last line of defense
as they say down south
bless her heart
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else